boy oh boy is this a big one  I'm living this incredibly blessed life  where I'm getting so many DMS and emails  and stopped in the street conversations  and the reality is is that  tolerating inconvenience  employing patience when it's kind of  shitty  this is a skill set that's been really  lost in the last half century when I  think about the [ __ ] that our  grandparents just bared and lived with  that we now complain about one to 100th  of that  very very very clear that we need to  really focus on this and so  with so many you know adversities ahead  the economy just a lot of tension  a lot of negativity is loud or it's just  a lot there's a lot you know this is  really the time to focus on being  comfortable in the discomfort maybe you  stay with your job for another year or  two to be practical and then you jump  get comfortable being uncomfortable